star trek picard's second season comes
to its conclusion with big reveals some
throwback themes and the return of a tng
cast member we weren't sure we'd see
again these are the easter eggs you may
have missed
in the star trek picard season 2 finale
farewell we get more than goodbyes as we
also say hello again to a familiar face
not seen in more than 20 years with dr
seung's genetically engineered daughter
corey left lost and confused having
sabotaged her father's work we find her
struggling to make sense of her life
when she is visited by a friendly
stranger we recognize him as long time
star trek fan favorite will wheaton
reprising his role as wesley crusher in
a jaw-dropping surprise cameo that
nobody saw coming a long time ago i was
known as wesley crusher but now i am a
traveler of all of space and time
last time we saw wesley was in star trek
nemesis where he had seemingly rejoined
starfleet that was a surprising turn of
events considering that wesley had
previously renounced his commission in
the tng season seven episode journey's
end in that episode he'd grown tired of
starfleet and left his life behind to
explore the universe with the mysterious
alien called the traveler it seems now
that star trek picard is treating his
starfleet return in nemesis with a wink
as wesley announces that he has indeed
become a traveler himself referencing
the events of journey's end but we also
get a stunning revelation that rewrites
more than 50 years of star trek lore
because wesley is more than just a
traveler he reveals that he and others
like him are responsible for the
supervisors like gary seven first seen
in the original series episode
assignment earth
in the final moments of the season 2
finale farewell we learned the identity
of the strange borg woman who arrived on
the stargazer in the season premiere
revealed to be the gerardi queen created
through picard's intervention in 2024
she has arrived looking for help from
the federation according to her there is
a dangerous new threat that only the
combined efforts of her board collective
and starfleet can solve once she
declares the dangers she brings up a
star chart on the stargazer's view
screen filled with plenty of star trek
easter eggs from benzard to draelax but
one stands out as particularly
meaningful the star system maxia can be
clearly seen when the chart first
appears and it's a system well known to
picard do you not remember the battle of
maxia
as revealed in the star trek the next
generation first season episode the
battle it's at maxia that picard had a
fateful encounter with the perengi while
he was captain of the original uss
stargazer in a brutal defeat the
stargazer was seemingly destroyed but
picard used clever tactics to save his
crew including a death strategy that
became known as the picard maneuver
eventually known by the perengi at least
as the battle of maxia it resulted in
picard being court-martialed after the
loss of his ship leaving a major stain
on his otherwise impeccable service
record of course he would be somewhat
redeemed in the battle when the
stargazer was discovered intact and used
as part of a revenge plot by ferengi
diamond bach for the death of his son at
the battle of maxia
of course the next easter egg is what
the gerani queen discovers as the danger
to the galaxy a massive spatial anomaly
that erupts with incredible energy
thanks to the use of the federation
fleet and board technology they're able
to avert a catastrophe but in the
aftermath something new and curious is
created a transwarp conduit seven of
nine being a former board drone
recognizes the phenomenon right away a
nod to the events of star trek voyager
where trans work conduits were seen
several times with seven having expert
knowledge of their fundamental nature
used by the borgs for interstellar
travel transwarp conduits can be created
by borg vessels themselves to travel
vast distances in an instant 7 of 9
notes that this new conduit is unlike
any ever seen before and it seems that
even the jaradi queen with her centuries
of collective knowledge is confounded by
it as well
what you see is a piece of the puzzle
whose final image is unclear but is tied
to a threat
one which requires close observation
who or what created this transwarp
conduit or for what purpose remains to
be seen and could form the basis for the
upcoming third season of star trek
picard
star trek isn't just known for its
characters stories and one-liners but
also features some of pop culture's most
famous musical themes the original star
trek opening title music has become
indelibly etched into the public
consciousness while the rousing march
from star trek the motion picture aka
the next generation's theme music isn't
far behind for decades star trek has
employed one of the movie industry's
best composers jerry goldsmith and
farewell features another of his star
trek themes in its closing moments while
picard and his crew along with his old
friend gainen toast each other at the
end of the episode we hear the
unmistakable theme from star trek first
contact a recognizable tune it played at
the close of that film as well as when
zephram cochrane made first contact with
alien visitors a vulcan survey ship here
it's used a good effect in a scene that
in some ways mirrors the final scene of
the next generation with picard joining
his crew in a casual setting to say
goodbye
for decades star trek has always pointed
to earth as a near utopia with several
episodes and movies describing it as a
literal paradise in star trek first
contact the crew travels back to 2063
and it said that in the years that
follow earth would cure many of its
worst ills from poverty and disease to
pollution and war visiting gaining outer
bar on earth back in the 25th century
picard asked for an update on rios who
stayed behind in 2024 to be with dr
teresa and her son gainen then tells
picard about the rest of rio's life how
he died in the bar fights as an old man
but it's what became of dr theresa's son
that provides an answer to a long time
trek mystery according to gaian young
ricardo grew up to be a scientist and in
concert with renee picard's discovery of
a unique alien organism on europa helped
devise new ways of treating and solving
the earth's pollution problem healing
the world and cleaning the sky
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you